it's a skill that's just as important
but far less studied than knowing how to
start things off we're typically
appalling at it we mumble we delay we
become strange we hedge and there's one
reason we make such a mess of it it's
not that we're in Napa Ford are more
cruel it's that we're trying to be kind
that's the origin of all our ineptness
stupidity and cruelty we hesitate to be
cold and try to be nice because we are
sentimental the essence of
sentimentality is the desire to be liked
even by those you don't like and can no
longer be bothered with it's a
narcissistic longing to continue to
receive the emotion of love without
wanting to pay for it but kindness has
no role whatsoever to play at the
charred end of relationships being sweet
and understanding Lily prolongs the
torture for the other person if we're
being so tender is it really possible
that we truly mean the dark things we're
ostensibly saying could we be so loving
and at the same time calling it a day
we need above all else to kill hope but
instead too often we just waft
our SEL Proust wisely observed at the
end of relationships it's the one who is
not in love who makes the tender
speeches parting lovers may end up in
the grotesque situation of one person
crying because they're being left and
the other crying because of the distress
that announcing the departure has caused
them tears that a mistaken by the
abandoned party for signs of care the
kindest way to end a relationship is
just to make extremely brutal speeches
of a sort that will leave the other
person in no doubt at all that you're
not an especially nice person the truly
courageous way to leave is to allow
yourself to be hated by someone who
that generosity there's no excuse for
delay don't imagine that you're doing
someone a favor by dragging out how long
they can persist in a benign illusion
that you want them their real priority
is to stop wasting their lives don't
imagine that they won't ever find anyone
else like you they may believe that now
it might even sweetly tell you so but
they won't believe it when they finally
understand who you actually are real
kindness means getting out even though
the holidays being booked and it really
will be terribly awkward to tell
everyone at this late stage there's
nothing at all wrong with deciding that
someone isn't for you there is something
very wrong with ruining large chunks of
someone else's life while you squeamish
lien sentimentally hesitate to get out
of the way
you
you